il a réussi carrément un coût mais comme
c'est un poney du nom castries il est
tellement mieux que j'ai pu casser donc
je pense qu'il a dû voter ils n'ont pas
pu il n'a pas pu finir parce qu'il était
tout seul la maca dans l'intimité d'une
quinzaine de micros et caméras nicolas
demajean raconte à marine le pen comme
trois de ces bêtes ont été attaquées
la présidente du fn est venu soutenir
ceux propriétaires de refuges et la
cause animale
c'est faux je pense que des millions et
des millions de français sont attachés à
améliorer la situation des animaux dans
notre pays pourrait tout le monde autour
de la table et réussir à trouver des
solutions qui soient des solutions
utiles voilà donc c'est là où ils ont
attaqué en pleine nuit
nicolas demajean montre une à une les
bêtes attaquées à la serpette fin août
par deux agresseurs
ce cheval mutilé remarche aujourd'hui il
ne battra jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
deux autres pognon aussi étaient lacérés
lui même en voulant défendre ses bêtes a
été blessé à l'avant bras et en portent
encore les stigmates le refuge a été
victime de la vague de mutilation qui
touche surtout les chevaux depuis le
mois dernier
depuis il est doté de caméras et des
rondes sont faites chaque nuit nicolas
demajean sympathisants et rennes dit
avoir aussi sollicité tous les
politiques sans vos carottes ya pas de
deux policiers qui sont venus me voir et
et nous comprendre aujourd'hui le
propriétaire et les propriétaires de
chevaux parce qu'aujourd'hui on vit dans
une peur il n'y a pas que moi qui vit
dans la peur tout le monde vit dans la
peur fait plutôt rare marine le pen elle
reconnaîtra pourtant le travail des
pouvoirs publics qu'ils font je cite le
nécessaire pour tenter de mettre fin à
cette épouvante sa visite aura duré en
tout à peine plus d'une heure